Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to answer the question,
is English really a Germanic language?
If you've seen any of my videos on
Germanic languages,
like my Afrikaans video,
like my Dutch video,
like my German video or like my north
dramatic languages video,
then you probably saw that English is
also a Germanic language,
but a lot of people write comments,
expressing some confusion over this.
They write things like,
Paul,
are you sure it's a Germanic language?
Are you sure it's not a romance
language?
Well,
that's a good question.
If a native English speaker who had
never learned another language before,
had to look at a page of French and then
had a look at a page of German or Dutch,
they would probably be able to
understand more of the page of French or
if they had to look at a page of Spanish
or a page of Italian,
they would probably be able to pick out
a lot of words that they recognize,
but on the other hand,
if they looked at a page of Dutch or
German,
they probably wouldn't be able to pick
out as many without deciphering the
words a little bit first.
So in that case,
why is English a Germanic language and
not a romance language in the field of
linguistics?
Languages are categorized according to
their genetic relationship.
Genetic relationship means that they
have a common ancestor and therefore
they have some common features that
distinguish them from other groups of
languages.
This type of genetic relationship
between languages can commonly be seen
in the grammar and syntax of the
language,
but the current vocabulary of the
language is not really taken into
account in its categorization.
Even when a language has a huge number
of loan words and it's vocabulary
changes a lot.
That does not change the categorization
of that language.
So because English developed from Provo
Germanic,
it is a Germanic language,
despite massive changes that have taken
place in its vocabulary.
The vocabulary of English has been
highly influenced by romance languages.
Romance meaning Latin in any language
that has developed from Latin,
like French,
Spanish,
Italian cetera.
So how much has it been influenced?
Well,
English vocabulary is 26 percent
Germanic and it's 29 percent French.
Wait,
you're telling me that there's more
French vocabulary than Germanic
vocabulary even though it's a Germanic
language,
that's all.
Oh,
but wait,
there's also 29 percent Latin
vocabulary.
So that means together 58 percent of
English vocabulary comes from romance
languages.
Wow.
That's more than I thought.
Another six percent comes from Greek.
Another four percent comes from other
languages in four percent comes from
proper names.
I can't really think of any vocabulary
that comes from proper names aside from
randy.
So if we ignore the origins of English
and that's grammar and syntax and just
focus on the vocabulary for a minute,
then English is largely a romance
language.
How did so much romance vocabulary enter
English?
Much of the French vocabulary entered
English after the Norman conquest of 10
66.
The Norman spoke of regional French
dialect called old Norman or Norman
French.
The upper classes in England spoke
French for around 300 years.
English was influenced by the Norman
French dialect,
but also by Parisian French due to its
prestige and cultural influence in the
following centuries,
huge amounts of French vocabulary
entered English and had lost much of its
old English vocabulary,
but in many cases there are pairs of
equivalent Germanic and French
vocabulary,
but within those pairs there's often a
slightly different meaning or usage for
the Germanic word and for the French
word,
an interesting example or the pairs of
words representing animals versus foods
that come from those animals.
The animals are represented by dramatic
words and the foods are represented by
French loan words.
For example,
cow comes from old English coop,
but beef comes from French.
Pig comes from old English,
picked up,
but pork comes from French Paul,
but I don't know what the pronunciation
would have been like in Norman.
French chief comes from old English
shop,
but mutton comes from old French and we
don't.
Snail comes from old English Snyder and
escargo comes from Norman French.
[inaudible] French also influenced
English because of its huge cultural
influence on Europe from the renaissance
period to the end of the 19th century
and even now to some extent,
but it's not just French.
There's also a lot of Latin vocabulary,
some Latin enter Germanic dialects.
In the early days through contact with
the Roman Empire.
On top of that,
some Christian missionaries were present
in Britain and the sixth and seventh
centuries,
and they introduced some Latin religious
vocab into English.
Many Latin words were also borrowed
during the renaissance period and also
during the scientific revolution of the
17th and 18th centuries were many new
words were coined,
coining,
demeaning,
newly created new words were coined from
Latin roots,
prefixes and suffixes to represent new
concepts in science and technology and
an industry.
So English is a Germanic language which
absorbed a huge number of French and
Latin words.
Yes,
basically.
But some people have a different theory.
Some people think that English is
actually a creole language.
There's something called the middle
English creole hypothesis.
There are big differences between old
English and middle English.
Of course there was the importing of
lots of French vocabulary,
but that alone does not make it a creole
language.
But there were other changes to the
grammar of English which became highly
simplified.
There was a lot of simplification,
like the loss of most now in cases and
gender,
so that aside from the possessive form
with apostrophe s and the plural forms,
most nouns in English don't have any
inflection.
Also,
adjectives used to have inflection,
but that disappeared to the word.
Inflection means changes to a word to
represent different grammatical
categories.
For example,
the word cat and the cat's paw here,
the apostrophe s is a kind of inflection
to show possession.
And we have one most but two mice.
So here the word is inflected to show
plural.
So let's take a simple phrase like the
good king and look at it in old English,
in old English.
Notice that all three words in this
phrase can change in the nominative
case,
say Gold Cuny in the accusative case,
thrown a golden human in the genitive
case.
Fast golden keuning is in the date of
case Fem,
golden tuning.
So the definite article changes the
adjective changes and the noun changes
depending on the case,
but the article and adjective also
changed depending on the gender and the
case endings are different depending on
the gender.
Let's look at a similar phrase,
the good Queen Sale.
Goal Day Quinn thought gold on Quinn
thought a go down Quinn and thought I'd
go down.
Quinn,
notice the different feminine form of
the definite article and the adjective.
This is just an example of the
grammatical complexity of old English.
So you can imagine how much it became
simplified by the middle English period.
Most of these farms disappeared or
merged together.
Now we just have a genitive case and the
others form a common case.
This is the type of simplification that
happens when creoles arise.
So it's very possible that old English
underwent a process of creolization
inserting lots of French vocabulary into
an old English substrate or underlying
structure,
but there might have been a different
reason for that simplification of
English.
Some people don't believe in the creole
hypothesis and they point to things like
some of the irregular forms that still
exist in English,
like irregular verbs or irregular plural
forms.
In a typical creole language,
those forms would have been regularized,
but of course creolization is not an all
or nothing process.
It's possible that English was partially
realized.
Well,
let's look at a couple of sentences in
English and let's look at the influences
we can find.
Let's see if there's more dramatic or
more romance influence.
This one's a newspaper headline.
Trump pushing immigration plan meets
with family of women,
killed in 2007.
Push.
This word comes from old French,
pulled say,
or modern French poussey immigration.
This word comes from Latin [inaudible].
Good optimum plan.
This word comes from the French word,
which means map or ground plan meet.
This comes from old English,
Mayton with this comes from old English
with family.
This comes from the Latin Familia
according to the source I used,
but there's also the French word for me,
which I suppose could be the source of
this word comes from the old English,
F or off woman.
This comes from old English.
We men or women kill.
This might come from the old English
Quillan to quell in.
This word comes from Latin,
so out of those 10 words,
five are dramatic and five are romance
words,
but let's have a look at a more casual
sentence because I have a feeling that
newspaper vocabulary tends towards
romance vocabulary more than common
speech.
I had lunch with my friend and we read
some books I have.
This is dramatic.
Comes from old English.
Each had.
This is also dramatic.
It comes from old English,
have been lunch.
The origin of this one is vague,
but it seems to be from a modern English
dialect.
Word with this is from old English with
mine.
This is dramatic.
It comes from middle English or means
friend.
This comes from old English phrase and
this comes from old English,
Ond,
or owned we.
This comes from old English way.
Read this comes from old English at that
done,
or they've done some.
This comes from old English book.
This comes from old English book,
so this time all of the words are almost
all of the words are Germanic,
so it's interesting that the majority of
English vocabulary comes from French or
from Latin,
but in the most commonly used words in
casual speech,
there tends to be more dramatic
vocabulary and this is a good argument
in favor of English being classified as
a Germanic language.
So do I think that English should be
classified as a Germanic language?
Well,
by a linguists criteria,
yes,
but most people don't really care about
the linguists criteria.
They just care about the practical
application,
the practical use of the language.
And in practice I think the vocabulary
is a very important element of the
language.
So I think it's fair to say that in
practice English as a hybrid language,
it's partly Germanic,
partly romance,
but that's my personal conclusion.
I'd like to know what you think.
Do you think that English should be
considered a Germanic language or do you
think it seems more like a romance
language?
Leave your answer in the comments down
below,
be sure to follow Lang,
focus on twitter,
on facebook,
and on instagram.
Those are places to kind of keep in
touch with me between videos and I also
post some little bits of bonus content
on those social media channels and I'd
like to say thank you to all of my
patrion supporters,
especially these people whose names are
on the screen for there,
especially generous monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.